everyone asks her how she's coping the
truthful answer is that she's not not
only her Charlotte's lost her 19 year
old son she also may never see the
person responsible held to account
because she's left the country
broken inside everything hurts
tonight Harry Dunne was killed in a
crash at the end of August the 19 year
old who was a twin was riding his
motorbike and was on his way to see his
dad was travelling on the right side of
the road he would have been approaching
the brow of that hill when he was hit
head-on by a woman driving in the wrong
direction he was taken to hospital but
he later died of multiple injuries
the woman had just driven out of RAF
croton in Northamptonshire which is also
an American spy base we've tried to
contact her but she hasn't responded Sky
News can reveal that the driver is the
wife of a US diplomat who claimed
diplomatic immunity after the crash
family members can be covered by it
Northamptonshire police have a clearly
identified suspect who has put
themselves out of reach we were aware
that diplomatic immunity had been raised
as an issue and we then made a major
application for a waiver in order for us
to want to take further investigations
and interview unfortunately we were
laterally advised that the waiver had
been declined and that the suspect had
left the UK the US Embassy has confirmed
she's gone I understand that someone on
the American side told the family to go
back to the u.s. in a statement the
Foreign Secretary Dominic rabe told Sky
News
I wish to offer my condolences to the
family affected by this tragic incident
I have called the US ambassador to
express the UK's disappointment with
their decision and to urge the embassy
to reconsider it so far all the family
have is a letter from the US ambassador
expressing his sympathy
Belushi's they didn't inner-self doing
this how can you just be like that just
get on the plane how could she be
allowed to through no fault of their own
this grieving family now find themselves
at the center of an international
diplomatic incident that only the US
administration can rectify Lisa Dowd Sky
News Northamptonshire